thank you very much let me just make
sure is my mic can you guys hear me okay
all right well thank you for having me
here my presentation is maybe about
thirty percent about data but it's
seventy percent about education and I
want to thank microsoft for giving me
the opportunity to speak to this crowd
about the work that we do at you know I
run a nonprofit called co.org most
nonprofits come talking about a problem
and then try to get you all sort of
excited about you know this problem that
we need to solve I actually think about
what we're doing is about opportunity
and unleashing America's untapped
opportunity I want to start talking
about in terms of a personal story at
this is a picture of me growing up when
I was little that's me on the left it
was me and my twin brother we grew up in
Tehran Iran and I lived there during the
time of the revolution and a war broke
out with Iraq and you know I spent most
of my childhood days kind of in the
basement while there's planes overhead
bombing our city and it was really not a
great place to grow up but I didn't
really have a lot of hopes for where I
would end up in my life but my life arc
changed one day when my dad brought home
a Commodore 64 and you know back in the
early 80s this may have been the only
personal computer in the entire country
and he gave it to my brother and I on
said you know that this thing doesn't
have any software or games on it but
here's a book and you can learn how to
write your own games it's called basic
and you can learn this and make your own
apps etc and like many others at that
same time I learned computer programming
and by the time I came to the United
States is an immigrant you know I was
way ahead of my fellow students and
friends and so while they were bussing
tables and waiting and working at gas
stations I'd get summer jobs as a 16
year old writing computer programs for
nearby tech companies and I was
basically on my way towards living the
American dream and I've had a fantastic
career and tech as a result and I want
to say you know the American Dream has
changed quite a bit you know it used to
be the American dream was about going
out west and building a log cabin and
you know panning for gold in
California's rivers but these days the
American Dream is about being the next
mark mark zuckerberg the next Kevin
Systrom building the next game changing
technology and also technology has
changed quite a bit when I started you
know computer programming was basically
around that Commodore 64 and then event
and you know largely about programming a
computer but with the advent of
smartphones and also the advent of the
cloud computers are touching everything
whether it's medicine whether its energy
and smart thermostats whether it's space
research entertainment transforming
transportation with self-driving cars or
contact lenses you can put in your eyes
that measure your glucose there's almost
nothing you can think of that isn't
being changed by technology and so
getting back to the story of me from you
know over 30 years ago there's a
question I have about what are what is
life like for today's kids at the same
age I want to introduce you to two kids
this is armando he lives in Washington
Park just north of Harlem in New York
City he's in fifth grade and this is
rahul she lives just about five miles
south of here in the highline district
in south seattle neither these are great
neighborhoods to grow up in they're
definitely better neighborhoods to grow
up and then post-revolutionary Iran 30
years ago and thirty years later these
the schools these kids go to don't teach
computer science and you know i have a
question of what does a career look like
for these kids or for a student entering
elementary school today starting
kindergarten this fall they'll graduate
in 20-30 what will their careers look
like i used to tell people that unless
you want to flip burgers when you grow
up or drive a truck anything you want to
do is going to be you know impacted by
technology it now turns out there's
actually robots being designed that flip
burgers and trucks have been announced
that know how to drive themselves so and
that's today so what's going to is going
to be like in 15 years what will life
look like for these kids if they don't
get exposed to these technologies now
since I run code org you know you can
see computers are changing everything in
most schools don't teach computer
science however people assume i'm here
to say that our kids should be learning
to code that's actually not my message
and that's not what our non pas
it is trying to do our goal is that our
schools should be teaching computer
science and even though you know my hat
says code our view over all is about
computer science and coding versus
computer sciences it's a little bit like
comparing grammar to English and
computer science is broader than just
learning one syntactic language it's
about learning about Big Data it's about
learning how the internet works and
things like that there's a lot of
misconceptions about computer science
one giant misconception is that computer
science education is on the rise we all
see everything that's happening in the
world around this technology in all
these startups it turns out that
computer science education is on the
very recent recovery after a 10-year
decline this graph shows computer
science graduates in the United States
over the last 12 years and you can see
the number we're at right now is still
lower than where we were in 2004 and
there's half as many women graduating in
this field than just ten years ago so
you know this is not a problem that has
been you know growing and like you know
the more opportunity is the more
students there are in the field it's
actually been declining at the same time
as opportunity has been created there's
another misconception that the reason
people are talking about this is because
the tech industry is desperately trying
to hire computer programmers in
California and the reality as i'm sure
you all know is every industry is
desperately trying to hire computer
programmers everywhere here in
washington state the picture is
particularly bleak currently there's
20,000 open jobs for computer scientists
in this state at this past spring 1000
CS graduates graduated from the
universities in this state and at the K
through 12 level only sixty two schools
teach computer science across elementary
in high school in this state that's just
bleak numbers but these numbers are
basically the same in almost every state
in this country you know in Missouri
there's also 20,000 currently open jobs
for computer scientists in Pennsylvania
there's also 20,000 open jobs in those
states actually graduate fewer students
then you know some of the more advanced
states from education standpoint and the
reason that I focus on elementary school
and K through 12 is students don't stud
this in university if they don't get
exposed to it in high school the high
school is when you decide what things
you're interested in if you look at the
job picture nationwide there's the these
are both charts from the United States
government's the top line is a
projection of jobs coming from the
bureau of labor statistics so 1.4
million jobs over 10 years the bottom
line is the projections of graduates
from the National Science Foundation the
Delta between them is a million jobs
over 10 years these are literally the
best paying jobs in the country and the
best paying college of degrees and the
salaries added up add to half a trillion
dollar economic opportunity and whether
you care about helping the US economy or
national competitiveness we're helping
you know the lower class reach the
middle class or just giving an economic
social opportunity ladder for people
this is a very transformative way to do
that that said this isn't only about
jobs ad it's about educating our kids at
one thing i like talking about though is
the stem problem how many people here
have heard of stem as in STEM education
at great many of you have it turns out
two-thirds of americans have never even
heard what that means it means science
technology engineering and math but if
you look at the stem field more than
sixty percent of all jobs in stem are in
computing and just under ten percent of
all graduates in all stem fields are
studying computer science so we have
this giant mismatch between what we're
telling students that they should be
studying and what our schools are
teaching and where there's actually
Economic Opportunity and and social
value added to the country so this
mismatch basically is causing this
situation where in most of STEM fields
there's actually too many students and
not enough jobs we have too many social
scientists too many psychologists more
mathematicians than there are jobs for
mathematicians in almost every stem
field there's an excess of students and
not enough jobs and then in computing
there's this crazy excess of jobs and
not enough students now computer science
isn't just about jobs it's not even just
about technology fundamentally it's
about logic problem solving and
creativity which is why we should be
teaching it to kids young at just to put
that in perspective you know this is a
picture of
the first computer from 1943 at I'm sure
all of us know how to use this thing
this here in comparison is the first
computer programmer and she wrote her
first computer program 100 years before
the first computer even existed Ada
Lovelace as you may have heard wrote a
theoretical program for the the Charles
Babbage theoretical computing machine
and I love this because of two things
one the first computer programmer being
a woman is awesome in a day when people
you know think that female computer
programmers are unicorns but then also
secondly it shows that this is a field
that really does it's not just about
technology it's about problem solving
and creativity and most importantly my
biggest message to schools is that
computer science on the one hand is
vocational it leads to these best-paying
jobs that impact every field but at the
same level it's also foundational you
know when I went to school every single
student would learn about you know the
insides of an animal and the digestive
system every single student would learn
about how a basic electricity circuit
works and every student would learn
things like the Pythagorean theorem and
it's just assumed that if you're going
to be an educated human being these are
things you need to be taught at and
there's still the things that every
single school teaches but I believe in
the 21st century it's equally
foundational to learn how an algorithm
works or how the internet works these
are there's nothing that says that these
things are less important or less
foundational in this day and age as the
world around us is changing at so the
real question is can the public
education system evolve you know we have
this trillion dollar a year public
education system in this country at when
you ask most people in America how do
you feel about America's public
education system you know they don't
immediately light up with smiles and you
know get all excited about how
innovative and agile or education system
it is they usually kind of grumble and
you know don't have a very positive
opinion but I believe public education
can evolve and you can actually look in
history and it has evolved you know
school used to use things like the
abacus for teaching basic math this is
how people learned math a long time ago
and nowadays everybody uses a device
that didn't even exist
see 70 years ago and so really the
question is how do we get computer
science taught in schools so we started
our work with a movement called the hour
of code at the hour of code is a
grassroots movement with hundreds of
partners to get hundreds of thousands of
teachers to introduce just one hour of
computer science into the regular school
day and the idea behind one hour is just
to begin participation for both the
student and the teacher and the parents
I want to play a very short video when
we had basically that we came out with
almost a year ago leading up to the sort
of the the computer science education we
climax of the hour of code last year to
talk about what this this movement is
about
your teacher says you guys are into it
we are it's very awesome Oh Lord has
partnered with 30 public school
districts across the country including
New York Chicago and Denver to provide
lessons in teacher training and writing
the largest education events in history
organizers said what they called an
ambitious goal reaching 10 million
students this week almost 15 million
signed up this week I'm proud to join
the students teachers businesses and
nonprofit organizations taking new steps
to support computer science and
America's schools
we've been so excited about it you're
learning getting your pine my god I ran
an hour coat it's easy to do they're
learning how things are created in a
technological world and that's their
world and their upcoming world every
district should do every district can do
it I'm actually seeing the kids don't
make your school start coding and this
is amazing yes I love it yes if you can
change technology you can change the
world attend does in every single
country to learn one hour of core
computer science can unlock the best
opportunities in the world no matter
wave wrong please help us get the hour
of code to a hundred million students
this year and I school doing
so that was about 10 months ago we were
at 40 million hours of code have been
served as earlier this week we've
reached 122 million hours served which
is a fantastic success and this is just
a success for us this is a success for
schools because most of this work was
done in schools not people at home and
also this started out as an American
movement but quickly a lot of other
countries basically came and supported
the same movement decided this is
something that's international so this
is a map of all the you know each of the
dots in this map is either a school of a
place of learning where students have
done the hour of code or people who
organize an event just to give you a
sense of the density of this this is if
you look in the United States and just
the eastern seaboard there's a lot of
dots each one of those dots has on
average 30 to 50 students doing an hour
of code and many of them are schools
were the entire school for a thousand
students did it just to show some of the
international support for this this is a
map of Europe Italy went crazy at and in
fact was the densest country in terms of
learning to code and they're now using
our curriculum as part of the built-in
curriculum for all schools in Italy and
it those of you who live in Seattle this
shows all the schools in the Seattle
area that did the hour of code now I'm
not here to talk about one hour of
learning because one hour is not very
much to learn much but it's still really
exciting in terms of changing
stereotypes for example in one week we
had more students try computer science
by far than in the entire history of the
field which is a fantastic achievement
for anybody who cares about the gender
gap in computing and in computer science
and technology now people ask me what
can you actually learn in one hour first
of all we teach kids that programming a
computer is fun and that you can build
things that involve cute characters and
we also include characters from
entertainment things that they recognize
and they immediately sort of get excited
by that the second thing they learn is
that coding doesn't involve or doesn't
need to involve learning about
semicolons and angle brackets and syntax
most of you who do professional computer
programming do need to worry about that
stuff but when you start learning about
it in school you know
it all involves dragging and dropping
and so getting some character on a
screen to do something mostly involves
dragging and dropping the code for what
they do and these days even at schools
like Harvard and berkeley the
introductory computer science classes
start with dragging and dropping code
figuring out how to build the logic
sequence before learning the syntax and
then lastly teachers learned that you
know kids can very quickly learn to make
cool creative expression art type things
and when making something like that you
learn not just about coding but also
about things like the angles and
geometry and it's a lot more fun to
learn about geometry when you want to
create something like that that in a
multiple choice question that just shows
you a bunch of angles and asked you a
question about it and so harnessing kids
and humans inner desire for creativity
is a great way to get them to learn I
want to give you a quick demo of one of
our tutorials this is probably one of
the world's most popular learning to
code tutorials ad oops so this shows you
the first few steps of the hour of code
you can see the angry bird on the screen
and he says you know help me get to the
pig and this over here shows the
commands he knows how to do and this
here is his program and so when you hit
the Run button he needs to move forward
twice so you can drag and move forward
command and now he needs to move two
steps forward and says congratulations
you just wrote two lines of code and you
can see the equivalent JavaScript for
the code that he wrote and you know just
having that small success of getting a
pig hit by a bird gets kids started
writing their first line of code and
then this here now they can write three
lines of code and then soon they learn
to you know put together more
complicated program so you know to get
this bird to get to the pig he needs to
move forward twice but then kids need to
figure out you know is it turning left
or right had and they commonly you know
this just teaches you think coding is
about giving the computer instructions
from its point of view people also
regularly turn right and then don't move
forward again because they don't realize
that when you talk to a computer you're
literally talking to the dumbest
possible device imaginable and unless
you tell it exactly
what to do it won't do it the way you
want it at but this is something you can
learn even as a six-year-old and
appreciate it even when you're 30 or 40
and you know with blocks you can start
making really really simple programs but
you can get much more complicated by
adding more logic as well at i'll skip
the video of this but this basically
shows a repeat block which is basically
a for loop and you can repeat 5 times
moving forward and as any of you have
done computer programming note you know
the moment you can do a repeat of
anything something can happen five times
or a million times or a billion times
and it unlocks a lot of power and the
and the beauty of computer programming
isn't and you can see of course this
also has a for loop and teaches you
these basics and the beauty of teaching
kids computer programming this way is
they don't need to learn about typing
and capitalizing and tabs and semicolons
they just learn to put together little
logic pieces and solving puzzles it
feels like a game and they literally
come home telling their pants I love
this thing and their teachers also
realize this is a lot more fun than math
class and they end up integrating it
into the curriculum so for us having
gotten over 100 million kids trying that
the real question is what comes after
the hour of code because in one hour you
can do that and have fun and for us what
comes after the hour of code is
basically integrating this stuff into
the school system to get back to the
students I talked about Rahel whose add
you know just south of us in south
seattle her entire school now teaches
computer science and she's one of the
first students enrolled in early
computer science class her goal is to
become a doctor in life but to use
technology to improve medicine and to
help save people's lives our mond who's
in 5th grade his teacher did the hour of
code but the kids loved it so much that
she ended up doing 20 hours of ongoing
exercises using our tools his goal in
life is to be a Navy SEAL ad and if that
doesn't work out he wants to be a
computer programmer to give you a sense
of the things we do besides the hour of
code you know we spend a lot of time we
have an entire engineering team about 15
engineers working on creating fantastic
online courses that combine an IDE
tutorials in one we've forged
partnerships with many of the largest
school districts in the country we're
training teachers to integrate computer
science into the curriculum and we're
also changing state policies some of our
metrics are success we now have 6
million students who've created accounts
to take full courses in computer science
we're in partnerships with all of the
largest school districts at these
districts all together represent fifteen
percent of the entire student population
of the country we've trained 10,000
teachers and we've changed policies in
18 states this has been amazing just
because this entire thing started less
than two years ago so for two years
change almost any nonprofit with numbers
like this would be excited and for us
this excitement isn't because of the
work we've done it's because public
schools are actually embracing this at a
time when you'd think schools don't do
anything they don't change and they're
not innovative this change is happening
because teachers understand it teachers
want this stuff they recognize it's
important for their kids future and
they're just doing it in the school
system is sort of catching up with them
another really exciting thing I want to
sort of delve into the 6 million
students at some stats on these kids
these are kids using our code studio
platform for learning which was launched
less than two years ago we now have a
hundred and forty thousand teacher
accounts on the system and of the six
million students they represent ten
percent of all students in this country
who've now registered in just in the
last year and a half two million of them
are girls and two million of them are
black and Hispanic students to put that
into perspective this country as a whole
has 500,000 female software engineers
and our schools at the university level
graduate 8,000 girls a year we have four
thousand girls signing up every single
day learning to code at much much
younger grades you know playing with
Angry Birds and iono and Elsa from
frozen but if even one percent of these
girls decide to graduate a major in
computer science will completely
balanced the scales of the gender gap
and also the ethnic race gap in
technology this is generally a picture
of our diversity across our students the
female the boy-girl population is almost
balanced
to population and the african-american
and Hispanic chart is actually perfectly
balanced the reason we achieve these
diversity numbers more than anything
else is we're starting young and
integrating this into school you know
most kids who learn this stuff out of
school it turns out are following their
stereotypes or more likely their parents
stereotypes when it happens in school
you don't really have a choice you know
third grade teacher just says this is
what we're all doing and we're all doing
it boy or girl and we end up reaching a
balanced audience so this has been a
fantastic success from the standpoint of
changing the color and the face and the
look and feel of who does computer
programming am I want to show a quick
demo of the tools we're using beyond
sort of the early elementary stuff to
show you how much more complicated stuff
can be taught in school pretty easily
I'm going to show something called our
appt lab add oops so this is basically a
design environment for making simple
apps at this over here is where your app
runs and i'm going to start designing a
very very basic app i can put a text
input over here and i can drag a button
over here i can put a canvas over here
and this is all inside a web browser
which is really important because
schools don't have IT teams they don't
like installing software and you can
very simply start creating a nap and
then assigning code for this app and the
code here can use drag-and-drop so i can
do things like you know setting my
active canvas to that canvas that i just
made and then I can trap events and if
you look at this I'm actually dragging
and dropping JavaScript and I can you
know create a little JavaScript function
that gets called when the button is
clicked and then this is the cool part I
can switch from blocks directly into
typing and start typing stuff so i can
say variable number equals get text of
text and put one
and you can even drag and drop into the
JavaScript ad and run things like a for
loop and for i equals 0 to 4 i'm not
really sure what i want to do this with
this that ad i can go from zero to numb
and then draw a rectangle from something
or something I don't know from zero and
I x 20
I don't even know what this will do but
we'll see what happens all right so that
drew a bunch of rectangles on top of
each other had that it obviously is
doing something I just kind of picked
those numbers out of out of a hat but
what's also cool for kids after you make
this is you can very simply share it and
type a phone number and it'll
automatically send that to your phone
and since it's a web app and as you
notice this little play area that we're
in is the size and shape of a phone you
basically get that exact same thing on
your phone so that the time it would
take for a kid in the classroom to build
something that they then get on their
phone is extremely compressed i did in
about five minutes but we can get kids
to build apps as similar to an Instagram
or snapchat as a whole homeroom sort of
school assignment that takes just two
days and if in two days you can build
something it does something like
Instagram and snapchat as a kid it blows
your mind especially if you're you know
living in a poor neighborhood where you
have no other route out other than being
either a gangster a drug dealer or a
basketball superstar this suddenly gives
you this other completely different
route out of your your life now the kids
who've been doing this stuff have now
written seven billion lines of code some
of this is JavaScript some of this is
dragging and dropping and to talk about
data these seven billings lines of code
give us a huge amount of data we now
have six million student accounts in
10,000 joining every day every single
time somebody hits a run button we save
the code that they ran we also know if
it was a puzzle that they were trying to
solve like the thing the bird trying to
get to the pig we know did the bird get
to the pig or not and we also know did
they use the optimal code for doing that
you know did they use the for loop to
get six steps ahead order they have to
go step step step step step which is
longer add and that gives us a whole
sort of level of insight into how human
learning works because you can measure
how long does it take for a kid to solve
a puzzle and if they make an error one
way what can we do to teach them how to
fix that error and so on we are just
scratching the surface of trying to even
understand this data at I want to show a
little bit of research that Stanford did
using some of the puzzles that we put
together that so this basically shows a
graph of students trying to solve a
puzzle where each dot on the graph is a
is a piece of code that a student ran
and then they change it and then they
run it again they move to another point
of the graph because as you know when
anybody is coding some people get the
right answer immediately but most people
try something and then they make a
mistake and they change it and fix it
down at the bottom right is the correct
solution at every other dot on the graph
is incorrect solutions and kids
basically sort of try these out until
they figure which one works at but to
show you how the this chart works and
said add cool little animation showing
all the kids start at one place and then
you can see the different things they
try to do at and these are all basically
the size of these circles are the site
are basically populations of students
and you can see different paths kids
take in terms of their learning as they
edit their code and then which paths end
up reaching a proper solution at and all
those sort of leaf nodes that end off at
the side edges are basically incorrect
solutions where it could get stuck and
doesn't find their way back this is just
done with solving one puzzle and and you
know millions of kids trying to solve
the exact same puzzle gives you this
picture basically what it takes for kids
to learn stuff it's really pretty
although I don't know how to actually do
anything with it to make our system
better because you know this is mostly a
pretty visualization what's cool is we
can take this type of data to then feed
back into hinting systems so as kids are
learning and they make a mistake we can
generate smart hints because we know
that you're over here on the graph and
what would be the next you know the next
change you should make to get back onto
a path where you learn or we can
identify patterns and the most common
mistakes kids make to figure out what
type of cognitive issue they have maybe
this kid is having trouble recognizing
patterns in loops or maybe this kid is
mixing up their right from their left
you know there's lots of different types
of patterns you can see and then use
those patterns to guide the learning and
maybe show them an appropriate video or
so on yeah in case you're interested
we've already made
a whole bunch of the data from our
puzzles available at the URL down there
at and this you know big data dump from
just about a few puzzles in our hour of
code tutorial we're planning on
releasing all of the data from all six
million students and hundreds of hours
of tutorials at an anonymized way so if
you go to that URL there's also a little
email signup form to hear when we
release that data as well and this is
data that we're going to make open for
anybody to basically to do research on
and will likely publish the top
questions we'd like help with ourselves
we're a very very small team and we
actually don't have any data science
expertise so our hope is to get other
people to help us answer the questions
for us um another thing we're doing in
terms of stuff with data is not only do
we have data on the students we also
have data linking every student to their
teacher and even every teacher to the
teacher trainer and we then you know run
these systems to train these teacher
trainers so this is a very unique
because in education you know you hear
about accountability and you know is a
teacher a good teacher a bad teacher you
don't really know and then there's all
this test taking to measure the teacher
when the stuff is done online you know
we're building online learning systems
that are used in the classroom in a
regular school not just for homework or
for after school which means we have
full measure ability of what the
teachers are doing in the classroom and
what the teacher trainers are doing and
the way our teacher training works is
you know we have trainers across the
entire country and teachers basically go
to their workshops and when they go
there they create an account they get
linked to ever train them so we can
track what happens in their classroom
which gives us a particularly unique
view on data and helps us optimize our
teacher training as well mmm i want to
mention something about our teacher
development workshops because to extend
any of you want to help with our overall
purpose this is something people can
help with as well you know we have
workshops that are highly highly rated
by teachers if you're familiar with Net
Promoter scores which is that the
industry standard for how people measure
you know whether somebody likes your
stuff our net promoter score among
teachers is a 90 which is extremely high
most you know in the tech industry the
highest
Promoter scores are amazon and apples
Net Promoter scores around 70 and it's
on a scale from negative 100 to 110 a
promoter score is 100 sorry is 90 and
we've partnered with all these major
school districts to host workshops
around the country that our most common
workshops are for elementary school
teachers where any teacher anywhere
convey sees show up and learn to
integrate computer science in their
classroom so if any of you either have
kids or no kids or know anybody who's
anywhere near elementary school please
ask the teacher to attend one of our
workshops and they can visit code org
it's free it takes only a day if one
teacher attends one one-day workshop for
their lifetime they'll have at least 150
or 200 kids that learn to code from that
one day that of time that they spend and
you know we have over a thousand
teachers every single month going
through these workshops we're trying to
double that number to 2000 and the best
way they spread is through the word of
mouth at so after the work we've done
over the last two years you know I
showed you that graph where computer
science was on a you know recent
recovery from a tenure decline it's now
the fastest spreading corson compete in
public education and in schools that do
teach computer science they're seeing
record enrollment by students this here
is the graph of the AP computer science
exam which is the college board exam in
high school right about here on the exam
is when code or glahn chhed so we see
the enrollment numbers are going high
very high however the problem is still
we have a long way to the go this exam
at the high school level is only taught
or this course is only taught in five
percent of US schools 95% still don't
teach it the elementary school courses
that we've put together now have ten
percent of us students enrolled the
other ninety percent still don't have
access so we're growing very quickly but
in a field that we still need to 10x in
terms of how we do so we have a long way
to go AB this wouldn't have been
possible without a whole lot of people
who've supported us you know not a
hundred thousand teachers millions of
students parents and lots of businesses
I want to especially thank our largest
donors
our largest donor happens to be
Microsoft because I used to work here
and had good enough connections and I
wanted to thank Microsoft in particular
for their generosity as well as Google
and the media or network and many many
other tech companies who supported us I
think that's it for my talk oh wait one
last thing which is how you can help if
you're interested in data which I'm sure
you are please check out our data at the
URL i said code org slash research the
other thing I would say is by our hats
and t-shirts we don't actually make
money from our the swag that we sell the
reason we sell it is to help change
culture and help kids think that this is
just something its mainstream our hats
have now been warned by Jessica Alba by
Ashton Kutcher by karlie kloss and also
by the President of the United States
said you know we've tried very hard to
get coding to be something that is
switching from being the super nerdy
thing it was when i was in school to
being cool enough that celebrities are
willing to you know where it proudly on
their heads this hat happens to be the
actual hat the president war which is
pretty cool and he unfortunately did not
want to keep it so I was very happy to
take it right back and then lastly
please refer an elementary school
teacher at to code or to integrate
coding to their classroom and then I'll
have to say the obligatory thing which
is if any of you are interested in
helping in this stuff we're looking for
software engineers and we're
particularly looking for data engineers
at we have this boat load of data and
nobody at our company actually has
expertise in how to use it at so if any
of you are interested please get in
touch with me add that's it so thank you
very much and I'll answer a few
questions if you have any all right
let's hear it for Hadi partovi Thank You
Heidi for that great talk clearly is
doing something very very noble my first
question given that this is the PI data
conference is you showed you a whole lot
of JavaScript what's the story with
Python it's surely when people get to
high school you want to make sure you
they learn Python oh yeah we get asked
by far the number one question we get
acid co.org is from students saying
what's the first language I should learn
at and we get a tons of arguments from
teachers
computer science to saying what we
should be teaching I would actually say
Python is the most popular language
we're told we should be teaching and the
reason we teach JavaScript isn't because
of its ease of learning it's because of
the number of platforms that have the
runtime built into it for sure python is
easier you don't need to worry about
your your curly brace matching ad but
you know or the first language we teach
really is just the drag and drop stuff
which teaches you all the concepts and
once you've learned that I think
switching from one language to another
is pretty easy in fact the drag-and-drop
tool that we use it could spit out
Python just as easily as it spits out
JavaScript and so once we finish with
our courses we may actually make the
Python equivalent of them as well at
because it is at the end of the day just
syntax I totally understand we just had
to tease you about that given that this
is PI data anybody have any questions
right there sure sure the question was
do we have interaction with us first
robotics which does similar kind of
stuff us first does after school
programs for robotics first of all we're
in an education we're a non-profit so we
love all other efforts that do get
things in education at we have some
differences with first they do more
robotics we do just software and the
other thing is us first is an after
school and I chose to do the hard thing
of getting this into the real school
curriculum which involves a lot more
stuff an after-school Club one teacher
can do it but every student doesn't
enroll just the ones who want to get
enrolled and then they need to you know
in a school of a thousand kids maybe ten
kids will take the after school program
our big advantages because we've managed
to tap into teachers who want to put
this into the real school classroom a
school of a thousand kids will have a
thousand kids getting exposed which ends
up leading to those diversity numbers
that but you know the coding that we're
doing which would that drag and drop
stuff most people to do robotics camps
the coding that they do also starts with
drag-and-drop so you know they'll learn
about it in in the classroom and then
they can go to the after-school thing
and build more cool stuff next question
first language I learned about it was
logo when you tell a turtle like repeat
for 450 right 19 a drop square one of
that that reminded me of that I was just
with you know telling you things how to
move from their perspective I was just
curious if that was a influencer that's
just a coincidental similarity yeah the
question is were we influenced by logo
we were totally influenced by logo I
didn't learn logo and I was young but
you know logo has been there's there's a
number of things logo and Kerala robot
are some of the oldest at their 30 years
old ways for people to learn this stuff
and a lot of what we're doing is just
basically bringing those make
modernizing them and making them a
little bit more mainstream and if you've
heard about our tutorials featuring on
an Elsa from frozen it is basically a
logo programming thing where Elsa the
ice princess is making ice fractals but
really she's just drawing lines and we
thought Elsa would be more appealing
than a turtle at nobody ever understood
why a turtle would be drawing lines at
butt out since Elsa does create ice
fractals and she has a super power to
make them and we think today's modern
superpowers learning to code but it's
really just a skin for the same models
as before and in fact the people who
invented logo are still in this field
doing this stuff and we work with them
had you know they haven't gone away
question yeah
yep so those two questions one is about
cross-disciplinary learning and I'm a
big believer in cross-disciplinary stuff
and you mentioned doctors learning to
code you know I think the intersection
of healthcare and technology is probably
the most amazing thing that's going to
transform humanity over the next 30 40
years and the only way you get people to
do cross-disciplinary stuff is if they
even are aware that they could do it and
the reason we're teaching computer
science is you know at the high school
and middle school levels when you learn
about all these fields it's harder to
become cross-disciplinary if one of them
isn't that's black box of secret stuff
you never trap touch you know most of us
live in a world where there's an expert
in one field but then they need to talk
to the computer programmer and every
field is looking for these like magical
unicorn computer programmers because
they don't know how to do it themselves
but if you get this taught into
elementary middle and high school
everybody will have at least the
foundational knowledge ER and least be
able to talk to the computer programmer
let alone be one at and I think it's
very important your next question was
about changing even just the 12 to
18-month sort of cycle of curriculum and
education I think technology will help
make that happen it's not my personal
goal that you know changing the school
system is hard at but for us what we do
is we try to change the school system on
the school systems terms and to
basically bring computer science into
the classroom kind of the way other
things are taught but one thing is
really important about how we do it
which is that you know the way most
things are taught in school is you go to
a lecture and the teacher gives you a
lecture and then you go home and do your
homework or read the book and then come
back to the lecture and computer science
is different in two ways one there's
computers in the classroom and you
actually do stuff in them in the
classroom much like a chemistry lab but
the other difference is that computer
can actually start giving you some of
the lecture and giving you some of the
learning as soon as you have the
computer actually guiding you to the
next thing the teachers role stops
becoming one of being a lecture and
becomes more of a facilitator and once
you get into that world you can get into
things like personalized learning and
then you can start accelerating the
they're kids at their pace and so on all
of that starts by getting computers into
the regular school classroom and we are
by far the largest deployment of
curriculum delivered via computers
straight to classrooms there's many
other efforts that create online
curriculum that is used at home like
Khan Academy or Coursera at X we are by
far the largest that actually is
bringing these into classrooms so it's
like the real school system is working
that way now our courses don't have any
personalization yet we're collecting all
this data that we could use to
personalize the pacing but we don't do
that yet go ahead there's so many
questions we'd like to ask you know I
have some really simple questions like
you know comparing learning between
girls versus boys between kids who have
a teacher and kids who don't have a
teacher and then if we spent money to
train that teacher that their students
learn more or not that's actually really
important to us because we're spending
millions of dollars on training teachers
and if it moves or doesn't move the
needle is really important so those are
simple types of questions actually even
measuring learning is not an easy thing
you can measure for kids solve the
puzzle did they learn something or do
they just follow the hints at you know
those are types of sort of questions
that then there's a whole bunch of
insights that can be fed back into the
system which aren't pure questions but
basically what would be the best hint to
give a kid if they're stuck from you
know we can actually eight you know we
have enough kids doing this stuff that
we can av-test you know when they're
stuck here give half of them this thing
and give half the other thing and see
how many of them solve it go to the next
thing and have have actually learned
what it took to get past that so that
you know we actually have an area where
people can crowdsource at you know we've
had the same exact puzzle tried a
million times so there's a place that
shows you know a hundred thousand kids
made this mistake in their code can you
give them a hint just for that mistake
and we have this area where people are
basically crowdsource typing
for the next hundred thousand kids that
make that mistake and then judging
whether those crowdsource hints are
better than algorithmically generated
hints is another interesting data
problem so tutorials are about to start
could I ask the people who have further
questions to come up to the podium and
for those that want to get ready for
their tutorials in the various from
please look at your program schedule and
we'll see how the tutorials well thanks
again ha d that was great I also have 5
code.org hats if anybody wants them all
right for the first five